[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 12 février
trois textes pour une oeuvre julien
gosselin adapte l'écrivain américain
john de l'îlot dans un spectacle fleuve
plus de neuf heures de représentation au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'espace albert camus s'est transformée
en salon d'exposition le mort par arrêt
de retour pour deux semaines plus de 70
oeuvres sera sans doute et une
exposition aussi du côté de plaisir
donné ses journées dans ses émotions
une vingtaine de toiles colorées qu'elle
a choisi de partager sont à découvrir à
la médiathèque du château
et c'est justement avec cette exposition
qu'on commence ce magazine donné ces
journées voit la vie en couleurs et en
émotions elle couche sur ses toiles
s'est ressenti ses impressions l'artiste
saint-quentinoise points depuis 30 ans
et ses toiles sont actuellement exposées
au château de l'a2 plaisir regardez
[Musique]
c'est dans la peinture que donner ses
journées à trouver comment s'exprimer un
besoin de spontanéité l'artiste peint
depuis une trentaine d'années ce qu'elle
ressent des sentiments triste des
sentiments gay un besoin de les partager
dans wii de les montrer de de connaître
le regard de l'autre justement à travers
une exposition et donc
de me dire tiens on aime on n'aime pas
pourquoi on aime pas aussi c'est
intéressant tiens je comprends pas ce
que c'est donc l'idée c'est pas toujours
de voir quelque chose sur une toile
c'est de dire tiens ça ne touche parce
que voilà donné ces journées a débuté la
peinture à magny les hameaux
avant les émotions elle couchait sur sa
toile modèle et voyages pour les
émotions elle a choisi l'acrylique
on peut pas tricher avec la clinique
parce que une fois que s'est posée sur
la toile s'est posée c'est pas comme
l'huile ça sèche très lentement
l'acrylique en un quart d'heure se sait
que c'est pas du tout la même technique
il faut pas se tromper
après bon il faut travailler les
couleurs par plusieurs étapes c'est tout
un procédé on peut ajouter les coquilles
d'oeuf pourquoi pas du marc de café
c'est marrant c'est ludique l'acrylique
c'est ludique voilà des émotions qu'elle
transmet par des toiles toujours très
coloré une vingtaine d'entre elles
s'exposent à plaisir jusqu'au 16 mars
à partir du 13 février plaisir va vivre
au rythme des guitares la ville et son
conservatoire ont prévu une semaine de
rendez vous autour de l'instrument des
concerts une exposition et une master
class des précisions de pascal en romano
le directeur du conservatoire il était
l'invité de grégory canal et nous avons
souhaité mettre à l'honneur un
instrument extrêmement fort et
représentés au sein des différents
conservatoires et évidemment chez nous
et nous avons souhaité aussi avoir le
privilège de mettre un coup de
projecteur sur la venue d'un artiste un
artiste vraiment important pour la
guitare qui emmanuel rossfelder qui
vient donc entre autres dans un des
temps forts de la semaine faire un
concert au théâtre espace coluche 1,1 et
mercredi ça c'est dès mercredi donc le
concert a lieu vendredi on peut le voir
comme un temps fort évidemment de ceux
de cet événement et mercredi il sera
parmi nous et de manière très simple
avec un projet vraiment accessible à
tous qui s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans la
volonté de ce projet qui qui peut être
vu comme un nouveau projet mais qui est
plus la volonté de là on peut dire la
feuille de route un petit peu que nous
avons au niveau de la ville de cette
feuille de route culture qui a été
impulsée par le dab le maire qui est de
rendre accessible la culture à tous et
de l'armée de ne pas la rendre
veux dire c'est pas de la vulgarisation
c'est plus de l'accession à quelque
chose d'un petit peu exceptionnel c'est
une expérience sans doute inédite pour
les spectateurs du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la scène
nationale présente ce samedi 16 février
joueurs mas ou de lennon une pièce de
julien gosselin et sa particularité 9
heures de représentation
lionel masse et à bonjour bonsoir alors
vous êtes le directeur du théâtre des
cinquante invités comme déjà vous avez
découvert cette pièce avant de découvrir
cette pièce j'ai découvert ce metteur en
scène il ya cinq ans c'est au festival
d'avignon où il avait mis en scène
puisque sa spécialité de mettre en scène
des romans c'est à dire des textes non
théâtraux
il avait mis en scène le mythique à
l'ipp mythique particules élémentaires
de michel houellebecq un petit spectacle
assez court puisqu'il dure est
uniquement quatre heures voilà ils
s'étaient virtuose pour un jeune metteur
en scène de galles et qui avait pas
trente ans qui avait 27 28 ans à
l'époque en et gt gt vraiment
époustouflés uniquement 4 ha parce que
précisons donc là 9h pour joueurs mao 2
il a aussi fait 2666 en 2016 et là on
était à onze heures c'est cette
particularité aussi qui vous a intéressé
il s'interdit absolument rien c'est vrai
que quand ils nous avaient dit qu'ils
allaient mettre en scène ce roman là
aussi assez mythique de roberto bolano
qui est un auteur chilien
c'est un roman de 1000 pages roman à
tiroirs
qui est pas terminée qui a été assemblé
après ça après sa mort puisqu'il est
fait de 5 de cinq romans mille pages
c'était quelque chose de quasiment
impossible il lorsque je les ai
découverts juste avant qu'ils soient
programmés au festival d'avignon
j'étais là aussi sidéré par cette part
cette maîtrise mais à tout point de vue
la maîtrise et du cinéma parce que c'est
un homme de lima julien gosselin la
maîtrise de la musique la musique est
jouée live sur scène
et puis la maîtrise du jeu de comédiens
de la direction d'acteurs alors pour la
pièce dont vous venez pour ce soir il a
tapé l'adapt trois oeuvres cette fois
donc de donne de l'îlot c'est un
romancier américain qui est pas toujours
facile aussi à saâles bordé oui c'est un
romancier kimon qui a maintenant quatre
noms un peu plus de 80 ans je crois
qu'il est né en 1936 1937 romancier un
peu culte qui à différents types
d'écriture une écriture qui est proche
de la poésie c'est à dire qui est très
condensée et qui est très opaque et une
écriture dans d'autres romans qui est
beaucoup plus délié mais dans laquelle
on peut entrer plus facilement
et entre ces trois romans qu'ils
adaptent à savoir joueurs mao 2 et les
noms on est sur trois écritures très
très différent 3 enregistre est
différent de données l'iso mais avec des
points communs bien entendu
9 heures ça comprend les entractes c'est
la pièce en elle-même comment ça va se
passer samedi
je pense qu'on peut pas aborder la
question du temps d'une pièce de théâtre
exactement comme on est d'ordre est la
question je pense qu'il ya un cap ou au
delà de deux heures trois heures on
rentre dans un autre espace-temps 9h ce
que l'on propose là c'est une aventure
véritable parce que en 9 heures en entre
en totale empathie avec les comédiens
pas uniquement avec les personnages sont
interprétés mais véritablement avec ceux
qui les interprètent avec les comédiens
en entrant communication peut-être même
en communion avec ses voisins c'est à
dire qu'on vit une aventure ensemble en
vie une aventure collective
c'est à dire qu'on se prépare presque à
ça et le temps
ces neuf heures peuvent parfois être
beaucoup moins lent que certaines
soirées au théâtre avec des pièces qui
dure une heure et demie donc faut
surtout pas et s'est fait un large au
souk ce qu'on dit aux spectateurs aux
spectateurs potentiels faut surtout pas
s'arrêter à ça et se dire on va vivre
une aventure tout simplement
mais après le temps joue aussi sur le
sur l'état du spectateur des spectateurs
sur l'état d'aider des artistes aussi
puisque on travaille sur l'épuisement
des artistes et puis sur peut-être en
relâchement aussi des spectateurs qui
sont beaucoup plus perméable à tout ce
qui se passait à tout ce qui se dit à
tous qui se montre et surtout que les
sujets abordés par julien gosselin dans
ses pièces souffle très fort il aime
parler de littérature mais aussi de
violences et notamment de terrorisme oui
mais il aime parler de ça c'est vrai que
c'est qu'il ce qu'il faisait avec
houellebecq ce qui faisait avec avec
roberto bolano et ce qu'il fait à plus
forte raison avec donne de lido c'est ça
c'est parler de la séparait de la
violence et parlé du terrorisme parce
que la violence c'est pas uniquement en
tout cas le terrorisme peut avoir
plusieurs plusieurs acceptions mais
c'est vrai que ce qui réunit ces trois
romans de du lido c'est c'est ça c'est
qu'il pas de la violence sociale c'est
qu'il parle de la violence réelle le
terrorisme la violence politique
ils parlent de tout c'est de toutes ses
formes de violence et ses trois romans
était écrit ça qui est très intéressant
c'est presque quelqu'un qui est
visionnaire alors ils détestent de lido
qu'on dise qu'il est visionnaire puisque
quand il écrit en 1977 joueurs il parle
de deux cadres de jeune cadre
new-yorkais qui sont au bord de la
rupture professionnelle et personnelle
et puis dans la route croise des
terroristes qui vont attaquer le new
york stock exchange qui se trouve dans
le wall trade center il aurait prévu
l'on sait alors j'ai pas s'il a prévu en
tout cas c'est vrai qu'il est toujours
dans une anticipation là son dernier
roman qui est sorti l'année dernière par
le transhumanisme donc c'est quelqu'un
qui est très
très ancré dans le temps dans la vie
d'aujourd'hui même s'il s' il un peu
reclus comme comme moteur il est très
ancrée dans ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et je vois on a beaucoup parlé de la
pièce qu'on vous d'avoir qu'on regarde
un extrait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une ambiance vous le disiez c'est vous
ce qui vous a plu pour le proposer dans
votre théâtre il s'interdit oui ici
c'est surtout qui s'interdit rien il a
une ambition il a une ambition folle et
ce qui a deux totalement fascinant je
parle et heures de maîtrise et une
maîtrise artistique maîtrise technique
c'est que tout se fait en direct à
l'aide des images qu'on a vu on a
l'impression que c'est un film
oui c'est un film puisqu'il est
retransmis là à part que ce film est
réalisé sur le plateau de théâtre en
direct c'est à dire que les scènes sont
jouées par les comédiens sont filmées
sont montés et sont diffusés en direct
c'est à dire qu'on assiste pendant neuf
heures un film qui est en train de se
faire et la musique que l'on entend est
également joué en direct donc tout se
fait en direct
il mélange absolument tous les arts mais
c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui a 30 piges
il ya 30 ans par dans donkey et qu'est
né aussi avec l'image gagne avec les
jeux vidéo qui est un fou de cinéma qui
était un fou de littérature dont comment
est-ce qu'on convoque comme on dit dans
le métier dans le jargon convaincant
rassemble tous ces arts sur un plateau
comment est-ce qu'on est un metteur en
scène de 30 ans en 2019 sur un plateau
de théâtre il faut mélanger tout ça
parce qu'il est né avec l'habitude avec
et pour voir le résultat
rien de plus simple joueur mao de lennon
c'est à voir au théâtre saint quentin
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce
samedi c'est suri à 14 heures merci
l'obscurité et le week-end sera aussi
solidaire comme chaque année le cabaret
du bout des prêts organise un moment
inattendu
pas de soirée mais un week-end pour
cette année deux rendez vous fait de
spectacles de numéros et des changes
pour aider le jeune nathan un mot sur
les artistes présents avec franck et
d'art le parrain de l'association en
termes d' artistes il y aura adriano
c'est un chanteur de pop de pop latino
on aura temps disparue ce qui est déjà
venu qui est chanteuse et comédienne que
l'on a pu voir notamment dans la comédie
musicale notre dame de paris mais aussi
dans les misérables allait passer
il ya quelque temps aux os x le télé
crochet de tf1 il y aura black eduardo
qui lui magicien il est suisse lyon n'a
pu l'apercevoir aussi à la télé c'était
dans la france a un incroyable talent
j'ai mis une petite note pascal beaucoup
d'artistes charles ibrahim alias magic
automates il est magicien aussi ça fait
plusieurs années qu'il vient participer
aux événements de nathan lui va faire de
la magie en close up
il va passer de table en table pour
faire des tours de magie on aura réuni
marceau il est l'initateur mars
orphelins fossé survivre et chansons
donc il nous fait l'amitié de revenir ça
faisait quelques années qu'il n'était
pas qu'il n'était pas venu on aura du
speed painting avec rené bès qui va
jeter les paillettes sur un tableau et
ce qui nous permettra une fois qu'il
aura fini de découvrir quels personnages
la destinée l'entretien est à revoir
dans son intégralité sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme et vous
pourrez notamment y entendre le
témoignage de stephen et guérison la
maman de nathan on part maintenant pour
mort par avec nos deux nouveaux invités
pour parler expositions et salons
regardez
[Musique]
le totalement mort par pris place à
l'espace albert camus de maurepas deux
semaines d'exposition pour des artistes
amateurs
on en parle avec nos invités véronic
rocher adjointe au maire déléguée à
l'action culturelle bonjour bonjour et
jérôme charrier photographe et invité
d'honneur de ce salon
bonjour véronique rocher cette année
encore près d'une centaine d'oeuvres
exposées
un petit peu moins 76 oeuvres exposées
mais sans artistes qui se sont présentés
effectivement au niveau du jury au
moment du jury voilà il nous en avons
choisi 76 choisi c'est bien le mot il ya
un comité de sélection que vous présidez
notamment jérôme charrier alors sur quoi
vous vous êtes attardé étant donné qu'il
ya énormément de forme d'art différentes
entre le
entre la peinture le dessin la photo on
avait tous un oeil à peu près un peu
différent sus suivant nos sensibilités
donc moi c'est vrai j'étais beaucoup axé
sur la photographie
madame rocher avait aussi son oeil sur
la photo puis également la peinture
puisque je crois que vous êtes aussi
membre depuis quelques années donc tout
ça a fait un joli mix avec également le
maire-adjoint et puis un professeur
d'histoire de l'art donc nous avons
réussi à sélectionner un pendant toute
la durée d'une journée les offres qui
vous sont ici présentés donc c'est
difficile parce qu'il y en a forcément
qu'on met de côté et on se demande si on
a bien fait ou pas mais comme tout comme
à chaque fois il faut faire un choix et
puis quand on voit le résultat on est
assez content de des choix qu'on a pu
faire parce que surtout ce sont des
artistes amateurs
alors ça y est attaché oui absolument
alors notre gars il sait il est il est
aussi bien sur la technique que sur le
coup de coeur que voilà tout un ensemble
faire un ensemble de l'aisance les
oeuvres spectron d'entre elles voient
c'est un petit peu saba elles peuvent se
répondre effectivement pas
automatiquement
oui on a essayé quand même bien sûr et
puis de d'avoir un large panel d'oeuvres
aussi un lieu dédié 100 artistes se sont
proposés pour exposer maurepas est
intégré dans le calendrier de maurepas
justement ah oui je crois vraiment c'est
quand même la 34e
exposition / bord pas
les artistes amateurs viennent de
partout jusqu'à paris donc oui je crois
vraiment que c'est reconnu maintenant
jérôme charrier vous vous exposez aussi
jeu l'éditeur êtes photographe amateur
plus qu'averti et on voit des photos
extraites de votre série de têtes en
l'air
comment vous est venue l'idée alors tout
à fait c'était une série j'ai commencé
lors d'un voyage à hong kong où on sait
très bien que la balle et les immeubles
rivalisent de hauteur et j'ai eu l'idée
en fait de relever la tête
et puis essayer de prendre le ciel on
était encadré par les par les immeubles
donc j'ai commencé cette série là bas et
j'ai continué un petit peu partout à
chaque fois que je vais quelque part
j'essaie je lève la tête parce que c'est
vrai qu'on est souvent habitués à
regarder nos pieds mais on lève pas
assez souvent la tête
donc je le fais pour vous il y avait
beaucoup de photos de paris parce que
c'est plus facile
c'est un terrain de jeu idéal la défense
également pour ces structures très
moderne et je vais essayer de continuer
encore retourner dans d'autres pays
notamment asiatiques je pense parce que
c'est vraiment là où se trouvent les
peut-être les plus grands building les
plus grandes habitations décrocher
pourquoi avoir fait appel à jérôme
charrier alors j'ai cru comprendre que
c'est un ancien mort passe bien est ce
que ça a joué ah bah oui forcément on
est toujours content d'avoir des mort
passe bien et puis nous avions vraiment
envie de travailler autour de la photo
et de
voilà on avait on s'était dit déjà
l'année passée qu'on souhaitait vraiment
mettre en valeur la photographie alors
il n'y a pas que le salon on l'a entendu
on a peut-être vie autour de nous il ya
aussi des enfants des visites et des
conférences on dépasse la simple
peut-être visite de l'exposition
oui tout à fait alors vous avez des
scolaires qui passent chaque jour avec
leurs professeurs et des bénévoles qui
les accompagnent souvent les artistes
amateurs ou
les ateliers dans lesquels ils sont et
puis trois conférences sont proposées au
grand public
gabriel endives et rauque et historien
de l'art qui donc fait partie du jury
depuis plusieurs années déjà propose ses
conférences alors y en a une
samedi 16 février et puis mardi 19
février dans l'après midi
ici même et tout ce jury aura son mot à
dire à la fin il y à une remise des prix
alors est-ce que déjà un coup de coeur
où vous voulez c'est encore le temps de
découvrir les oeuvres exposées d'entre
vous fait pas tous les deux partie du
jury alors on laisse le temps évidemment
le temps faire et puis il n'ya pas que
nous jure il ya aussi le public qui va
s'exprimer les enfants vont s'exprimer
voilà on est là plusieurs prix à
proposer pour la main on se laisse
encore un petit peu de temps ça vous a
peut-être donné d inspiration vous pour
de futurs clichés il ya toujours des
inspirations partout où on va c'est sûr
et puis en fait ce qui est très
intéressant dans ce type de salon c'est
qu'on s'ouvre à l'art c'est à dire que
on a forcément des affinités en fonction
de l'art qu'on peut faire ou qu'on aime
mais ça nous permet aussi de voir
d'autres choses il ya du dessin il ya de
la peinture abstraite il ya la peinture
futuriste il ya des sculptures donc tout
ça c'est magnifique je trouve pour même
pour le jeune public est ici de ceux de
pouvoir s'ouvrir à l'art de cette façon
merci à tous les deux alors le salon a
débuté le 8 février dernier à l'espace
albert camus de maurepas il se tient
jusqu'au 22 février et à cette date à 19
heures il y aura la remise des prix
[Musique]
à
depuis huit ans la ville de guyancourt
consacrent un temps dédié aux femmes des
animations sont proposées dont une
exposition
cette année elle fait part aux affiches
un sujet de marylène iapichino aucune
femme dans les 15 personnalités
préférées des français
les objets ne sont pas des femmes l'un
vers sont plus des chiffres des slogans
des visuels chocs dans le cadre de son
temps des femmes
la ville de guyancourt se pose la
question l'égalité où en est on l'idée
étant de réunir des artistes autour des
thématiques la de l'égalité avec l'envié
en tout cas de montrer des divers
supports du dico du discours féministe
aujourd'hui que ce soit du street art
comme avec les oeuvres de mystique qui
sont juste derrière moi on va voir aussi
de la vidéo de la fiche de
l'illustration aussi du dessin de presse
montre aussi toutes les formes que prend
que prendre le discours autour l'égalité
aujourd'hui une dizaine d'artistes ont
répondu à l'appel parmi eux arnaud
corbin il interpelle le public avec des
chiffres chocs sur des visuels et je me
dis et je m'engage pour que pour que le
monde qui nous entoure et tout les gens
avec qui on travaille plus que soi même
on essaye d'être respectueux il vit dans
un monde un tout petit peu plus
tranquille tout petit peu plus
harmonieux un tout petit peu plus
respectueux l'exposition soyons affiché
est au centre de ce mois consacré aux
femmes et entraîner avec elle de
nombreuses animations pour toucher un
public le plus large possible
on a aussi des débats on a aussi au
théâtre notre ferme de bel ébat notre
centre culturel il ya aussi des
représentations théâtrales et on a aussi
une forte chaque année une forte
sensibilisation envers les enfants et
les plus jeunes et il n'y a plus de 300
jeunes qui se sont inscrits revenir avec
laurent enseignants visiter l'exposition
et puis aussi travailler c'est ça qui
est le plus important
travailler sur le sujet de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 16 femmes
sont décédées sous les coups de leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint en france
on part maintenant à magny les hameaux
la maison de l'environnement accueillez
le quatrième trop plein des voix
une vingtaine de candidats se sont
affrontés sur scène face à un jury est
aussi le public qui pouvait voter pour
son favori
marylène yapi chine et grégory canal et
ce soir il en va bien
21 candidats coachée par l'équipe de la
voix en scène pour assurer la meilleure
prestation possible et se faire plaisir
pour me donner encore des nouvelles de
nouveaux objectifs en fait donc je me
suis dit pourquoi pas en fait tout
simplement
le but c'est de donner une chance à des
gens qui qui qui tâtonne qui savent pas
forcément s'y sont faits pour ça s'ils
ont envie de faire ça jusqu'au bout de
leur vie n'ont pas et on est face à des
professionnels
en plus des trois catégories jugés par
des professionnels le public avait aussi
sa voix a donné pour désigner son
chouchou de la soirée le concert était
diffusé sur internet message des votes
ont pu dépasser les frontières de magny
les hameaux
la preuve en tout les styles représentés
là je
ainsi que tous les âges
à 9 ans et demi ça n'aille la plus jeune
de la compétition pour l'encourager son
équipe de foot lui a fait la surprise de
lui envoyer un message
[Musique]
cinq heures de show qui ont récompensé
quatre artistes dont le rappeur et nîmes
teint kirtas dans la catégorie auteur
compositeur interprète nos droits et nos
devoirs
on nous dit que l'homme est libre de ses
choix sauf qu on oublie de préciser que
seul l'argent est roi
[Musique]
le site humour revient pour une deuxième
édition un plateau pour découvrir de
nouveaux talents mais aussi des artistes
reconnus pour cette soirée lors hyper et
hélène bulliard et me lehner et mathurin
messelet magny les hameaux recherche
elle des talents aussi mal chanteuse
musicienne humoriste une soirée spéciale
vous sera dédiée à l'occasion de la
semaine femmes du monde 2019 pour vous
faire connaître le plus simple le
contact et apprendre auprès du centre
social et michel thomas pain l'instant
le monde actuel ces personnages souvent
solitaires donne l'impression d'un temps
suspendu
ses toiles sont exposées jusqu'au 17
février à la galerie saint simon de
versailles
un roman un film est maintenant une
pièce de théâtre chez les rozes rien ne
va plus le mariage tourne au carnage
grégory barteau met en scène mathilda
may et pascal de deux mots long la pièce
est à découvrir à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux
extraits l'amour au début c'est
n'importe quoi
opel a raison on paie les crues du
bizarre bizarre comme s'est marié
on sait j'avais compris on rigole que je
ne peux plus te voir aucune idée de
livre à une minute de plus avec quoi sa
nudité
je souhaite que les choses se passent de
manière civilisée voilà civilisé le
divorce c'est la guerre
[Musique]
il a joué là où je suis je reste
d'accord c'était la mienne à
saint-cyr-l'ecole vous pouvez découvrir
l'histoire de joseph hoffmann à paris en
1942 l'étoile jaune doit être portée
josef hoffmann est alors bijoutier il
propose à son employé de prendre la
direction de sa boutique
la pièce récompensée de quatre molières
est à saint cyr l'école c'est samedi 6
février
étant donné le vol organisé e subitu
commerces juifs en ce moment pierre le
ve vous cédez le magasin
oh
je me suis apte man j'aimerais que vous
ayez des rapports sexuels avec isabelle
le temps qu'elle tombe enceinte
[Applaudissements]
avec son patron planqué au dessus de nos
têtes contre ça devient trop dangereux
monsieur ammann s'est engagé à temps
d'aller d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est la fin de six est une culture
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
revoir cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro
[Musique]